well so sorry do you mind continuing the
thought you were having about how you
don't think that white has enough if
Black gets the King to d7 yes because
when you go Queen d4 I'll step away King
e8 let's say and then if you go Queen
it's a check I go King takes day 7 Queen
takes head seven and then Queen takes d5
and you're going to have this Queen d1
here
d5 checks yeah so maybe this might
fizzle out but
but you can see that the position was
untenable for young I mean he can't wait
with the wish upon a freight he had to
get out
he has to get out looking of idea
because this head six one is quite a
monster right he runs away from the
neural network age six pawn still no
move in the game between MBL and and and
Alexander grishnack I think the other
game we might want to get fishies
thoughts on if we can is the Dingley run
any Giri game Robert that that game
seems to be getting closer and closer to
one where a niche is proving he can hold
yeah I think he's basically safe isn't
he yeah he looks safe now but earlier I
was loving dings position but with the
trades that have ensued it looks to me
like blacks should be okay here right
but he's not completely home and dry
let's say I goes I have to play C 4 and
C 3 now
stop to stop King bee to King c3 I mean
alternately I can allow white to go to
c3 and wait passively I guess it's also
possible but I'd like not to do it right
so let's say I go see for Bishop c2 c3
then you have rocketry right and now
it's tricky for me I probably have to
play a six
and the point of everybody is if white
takes e4 the a for pawn Falls if you
take c3 maybe the a for pawn Falls but
that's why you played okay sixes so that
rooks III can be met by Bishop a4 and
rook a3 should be fine but just maybe
eating to us is three I mean I I think
two versus three is ready saved so I
wanted to do Roux k6 if you play a file
then I think of Bishop b5 you should be
three and then I'm fine because then you
will not be able to crawl off the boat
so I am within my drawing zone but
pretty force hanging right even now if
you play oh you mean without route exit
yeah that's true oh yeah that's a good
point
so then after a fight I would have to
play f5
f-five Jehovah but now my threat would
be Bishop b5 III yeah and I think
it doesn't work for you anymore here
correct yeah in fact why can't even do
anything because as soon as you leave
the a5 pawn black we'll take it and
trying to bring your King around somehow
it doesn't seem to feel that yep so if
we step back to a4 with on day four I
think rookie six may c4c 300k six maybe
a way to go
we see that in the live position still
no no move has been played by ding li
Ren but we do have a little bit of
action back again and MBL grishnack so
let's head over
ruk t1 check vichy suggestion was played
and king east 7 rather than taking the
pawn
but now I would like to play Roxy seven
takes G seven right you don't even
bother with b7 you try to get these two
passed pawns over here but you might
just play for anyway and a group g5 then
you have rook HG hmm and if I take take
you will use the a pond to in the Jeep
on and that's it
right three and nothing time to protect
with the king
yep okay back to the wife position if
that's the case is there something
it it's honestly a very clever move
because you know rook d7 check then I
take on e6 or you know rook c7 check
then I take on e6 and you lose out the
opportunities to force the King to g8 so
I think Kirk is he's a wily defender
he's never gonna go down without a fight
but I still believe in his position in
terms of holding this because they're a
pawn
yeah yes no clearly that's what he had
reckoned with and so good foresight by
him but well this couldn't of being
revisit this line it Stephen backs him a
lot more than we get to the curse of
these days yeah well I was gonna say it
could be one that he really regrets as a
missed opportunity because not only did
he seem to be close to a winning
position but grishnack was also under so
much time pressured that if he doesn't
convert or fights find some way to get
something here he's gonna regret it
yeah maybe this one is settling in now
it works its own King e6 and pushed away
upon ahead and that seems like a decent
formula is that is that something you
you know you struggle with
psychologically as a the top player
obviously you've played it in many of
these events and against all these guys
is that a is there a hangover affect how
quickly do you have short-term memory
where you don't beat yourself up but at
that sort of a missed opportunity
um
it depends I mean sometimes you see it
right away at the board what you're done
and then you're furious but sometimes
things move along and
other games influence your thoughts and
and and well you basically move along
the tournament right but I hope feeling
in this tournament with three guys tied
on plus one you will kick yourself by
there every chance you feel if you are
able to squeeze more out of it and could
be leading right so that's going to be a
factor here so there's there is a little
bit of an emotional kind of hangover if
you will right I mean there's a rest day
help that sometimes stir yes I mean is
very nice I think to calm down after
winning and forget about losing both
ways yeah but sometimes when I went to a
three you're getting euphoric and that's
not healthy either but I will say I like
to have Fabiano's playing again not
going for the forcing lines he's just
gonna he's going full alpha zero here
he's just gonna keep the pressure the H
pawn I'm not gonna allow any any forced
way out of my mating net ideas Queen f6
is on the agenda everybody and if I move
like king e7 is played I think Bishop d4
or no Bishop g5 check is just winning
okay okay
and then what do you do
it's funny I was gonna say Queen f6 for
that walk witnesses well it kind of
transpose checking these seven takes
yeah you do your little wheel of checks
you can maybe do like an inchworm idea
you can play Queenie for check now
welcome these seven
is there sir but this is getting
unpleasant if I go queen g4 check I was
gonna say if I quit question 5 and then
queen bee for now rushon
yeah the situation where pushing your
pawns forward is actually really bad for
you because uh once age 7 Falls g6 also
is a goner and you lose out on some
checks for having a pawn on f5 but I
think you really have to well now maybe
Queen C 3 works on the board and the
white position you mean Queen C 3 yeah
Queen C 3 because I think it just holds
together to help me enough to breathe
right because black really doesn't want
to push anything and necessarily how I
really like Quincy
I'm gonna get greedy for a second is
there a clear problem with Queen takes a
two instead of Queen C 3 again bishops
and I don't have this what Queen D is
made Queen its mate it's funny because I
saw that meet way long ago we were many
moves ago and now I forgot about it and
that's the problem o Queen e1 check has
been played by the way I think will
quickly see King G - what why not go to
G - I guess
in terms of the time pressure we know
that yonder I mean I'd be very impressed
if a Buford King h2 and that Kim G - at
the point I wanted
yeah the only thing I could think of is
he wants the king obviously on the d5
square if that pawn has ever captured
later with check right mm-hmm
so many ways after Queen c3 if I want to
go I can go Queen a1 check we need five
right so is he gonna play f5
huh indeed keep white totally nice
the queen is the Queen can move from f3
I mean you can play bit o no Bishop g5
you have 24 yeah black is better now
yeah
suddenly oh wow
so King edge king itch - what's the
correct move King H to f5 Bishop f4
there's no Queenie for trading this
Bishop c5 maybe yeah and DC yeah this is
it's getting closer to position where
white is uh reopening the door for black
to get winning chances
so King G do you play a file if I go G
for you go Queen b1 and many are
threatening to exchange Queen so that's
the end of that that's a very very nice
idea Queen to be one guards f5 and the
point everybody is if the Queen's come
off the board we're liking Blacks
chances not just because of the long
term grünfeld
two-on-one but a suddenly h6 turns from
an asset to a weakness very quickly
right so the part of the to translate
the storyline of how we're all
evaluating this if f5 can put white in a
tough spot and these queens are traded
the palm neo she is doing very well
suddenly
g2 has been played we'll find out well
fi has been played is y'all playing for
a win suddenly well I think if I was
necessary just to stop bones Queen f6
ideas so it's a why not have fun yeah it
feels more in Yan style instead of kind
of groveling shuffling back and forth
you play no if I get a 5 and I don't
know I mean I'm thinking that and
Danny seems to think the same that black
is the one who's gonna be trying to
press this one I agree I don't even see
a way for him to why the exchange of
Queens oh well and if they come off
again it's it's what we've been kind of
saying throughout the beginning of the
game the story line switches very
quickly if the Queens are off the board
and so it turns out my Queen f3 wasn't
so good in the end
maybe you should have gone queen d4
instead of Queen by suggesting could
possibly be bad
yeah Queenie one an f5
and you already had me thinking like
because Bishop f4 there might be even a
capture on f4 and Queenie for still yeah
some of these King and pawning games are
gonna be really bad for white what a
quick turnaround here and again Nepal
Miyagi managing managing I think the
defense of this position really really
well keeping keeping Caruana at bay not
even under any any kind of bad time
pressure they only have eight moves to
reach time control the opposite of
grishnack situation although he also
seems to be holding I kind of want to
check back on Dingley Rena nice giri cuz
that game just I feel like it's not
going the way we think it's gonna go
every time if we go back there a nice
Giri has a king on c5 and and he's held
on to the C pond I mean III don't think
black could possibly be better of course
not but this just I don't know this
doesn't seem to be the way I thought
this game was gonna go with Dingley Wren
having been better earlier you know
you know we are talking couple of days
about reminding me of bad memories I
think this one is going to Alicia's
reminding himself because he lost a game
like this with a share
in I think
Pyrus blitz and rapido Sanjay where
exactly this position here King on c5 an
apology for any overpriced Elon I think
a if I Bishop b5 happened making a draw
somehow he lost that pawn then
in fact the maxim one so
I'm glad I'm no longer the person who
brings up the bad memories I've he
reminds me reminds me of bad memories
all the time so welcome to my world here
okay but well I like to see three but I
can't say is anything wrong with this
the king is so dominant that I think has
the same effect of squashing any plans
that white has on this side maybe I can
go all the way with through catch one or
something but it's hard to believe I'm
gonna make a move like g6 first I should
be okay
can I start going it looks very expected
ability so kind of g4 and pushed up on
even g4 let people IG for the next six
and then how do you progress
yeah and maybe I just regret it but I'm
trying to I think it's equal but I can't
see any way for white to make progress
on yeah it's it's it's the thing is that
with the rook on a6 you for the viewers
watching you need to keep that rook on a
light square so the bishop can retreat
and protect it so for example if black
had played instead of rook a six like
Jesus or something yeah and then you end
up taking the pawn here is to show the
line right rook exactly and this is a
big problem if the rook were on a six
Bishop b5 would save the day so this is
part I mean the other key thing about
the rook on d6 is are we threatening to
play Brooke f6 in some positions maybe
I mean I'll point out that if something
happens where white does nothing rook
f6f-5 can be met by Bishop b5 I'll
blockade on a6 with the bishop maybe an
f2 is a problem I don't know ah this
would be how Serie but over friends I
think I was trying to show the line as
you said we're what's the variation
we're a nice Giri over presses and loses
that's the variation right there yeah
well I should look it up and see exactly
how he lost but it was like this I mean
you thought that he couldn't lose and
suddenly
something he did right remind everybody
of something something fishy and non has
has done twice the winner of the
candidates tournament will challenge
Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship title quick shout-out to
any new viewers who are here and
wondering what's it all about back in
this MBL game speaking of maybe pushing
things too far the Caruana might have
done against yana pom yoshi is MBL going
too far away from this a pot I'm
starting to wonder if
he should always be able to run back and
at least stop it on a one but that could
make drawers black strawberries here
right because you then just house so
let's see if I go route b5 would you
bother with a seven or would he just
play a three and try to push it all the
way back
a three Rock Jake's run the king of King
yeah I guess he's easy
but within there's rook d7 check King
say five okay so I'm just gonna rip d1
but yet me over b8 and I'm not gonna be
any worry I've slept like a 2d one I
want to play King defy rocky - rock 88
and just or yeah here King d5
and a blue key to play rook a four for
instance and start all your bones are
loose and quite a few will drop off
yeah I'm still trying to saw make e
seven work but it's
maybe see korchek work somewhere but I'm
sort of gorillapod og5 young
yeah if I get to keep my e-pawn you know
I don't really care about the Jeep on so
I just try to e7 and c4 jack and all
that stuff but this is this therefore I
should first play okay
and try to collect that bomb yeah that
makes perfect sense
so e7 still
and then came these six
but you're saying that I'm not actually
threatening yeah I was gonna try so I'm
gonna c4 c5 c6 but that doesn't work out
there so yeah
rook t1j might be actually tactical
issues collecting the bond back so you
actually wrote d1 check here just wins
for maybe maybe it'll be five okay seven
is just sensible ways position with rook
in the in the beginning Danny
so don't be five and just to okay seven
let's be pragmatic and I mean it can
even be looking to be a actually because
if you go back to G flag Austria and
then just play a three a two and come on
so one of the other
that looks looks like the hold
I don't see any way forward for Maxime
here because you need to stop the a pawn
at a pawn who runs then it solves on
white who's the one trying to make a
draw so I think that rook d5 rook g5
line is maybe pretty likely to happen
and for you've reached move 40 you
have more time to think
so he'll be confidently holding this
game and what a save it it will be
because Grisha had three good positions
in the first three rounds made draws in
all those games and now with the black
piece is in a worse position it looks
like he's going to survive so a very
mixed tournament thus far for Alexander
Grisha yeah indeed if you're just
joining us we were all talking about the
potentially critical moment as being
back here on move 30 when grishnack was
still under serious time pressure and by
all accounts it seemed that white should
be moments away from converting on
something although Wesley so did did
suggest a very creative defense on
rookie four in the in the chat with this
move Knight c3 but until I wonder if he
said that instead of Bishop a3 check
rookie four first was the precise move
order
the difference is that now there's okay
now there's no Bishop e6 well there is
but after Bishop e6 it takes me know you
take them bishop on e6 and apparently
there's some kind of Bishop g5 check
stuff but if I'm remembering correctly
it's a teeny a truck f 395 and rookie
rube ef4 and I get to excel
maybe nothing like this yes there's
still 97 here but no no kept seven all
right Dell rookie seven I missed it
sorry yes um something very deep but I
remember looking earlier and your
intuition was correct I mean even for
the world's best players Vichy I mean
how hard is it is it always a
psychological struggle when your
opponent is under so much time pressure
to not play some quick moves there I
mean it just feels like the way we saw
Maxime handle this he had more than an
hour on the clock and it's okay it's
easy for us to be critical we understand
that but it just seems that he
mismanaged taking time because because
maybe trying to make some moves quickly
and and get grishnak under even more
problems on the clock yeah that's that's
generally a classic error I mean one
that goes into the list of things that
simply she must not be done right it's a
very fine art to blitt someone and I
think let's sing someone too early
you should you can just about try this
when the other person is down two
seconds but even there I don't think
it's been a successful strategy for me
when people are with seconds and you
present them with choices like that
sometimes it turns out right when I
played cop of the first time I remember
getting the distinct feeling that he in
fact aimed for this sometimes you hear
like five minutes for the last several
moves and he would inexplicably spend
four minutes thinking and then start
blitzing and you get caught up in this
cause you got so excited hey he's down
two seconds and I can do this
and it turned out he spent those four
minutes calculating some lines very
exactly and then he lets you blitz and
you blunder here and there and then he
converts everything classic Harper
yeah no it's I think one of the deadly
sins yep
well it's hard it's hard it's easier for
us to let to let you be kind of honest
and and critical about that cuz it's
something that the best players in the
world struggle with it's harder for us
to feel like critical of Maxine when
he's but clearly we could tell that he
was miss managing his time and letting
the advantage slip as he was playing too
quickly right that night is even more
loose but you have this thing that
sometimes these extra moves the bishops
play something but you can't know that
there's no but we can go wherever yeah
should be should be a draw we haven't
looked at the at the wrong house gang
against Alec senko at all since we've
had you I don't know if we want to take
a quick peek here it looks like I want
to take Vichy back to that 8xb 392 b3
decision okay I can't for the life of me
understand 863 so Vichy I'm hoping you
can illustrate not just to everyone
watching but also to me why you would
ever play a takes b3 here a set of night
eggs here I mean I think you just seemed
obvious know you really should be fab
you should be yeah I can't explain it
but
I'm just a full refund yeah just say for
you
so you're saying probably comfortable
cause I mean you're saying Roberts
putting you in a tough spot to explain a
bad move that's how I feel all the time
so yeah maybe black can do some maybe
six a finite C for contact for the like
squares or something but
it feels like you know a desperate
measure just to
but maybe it holds in the end but this
is clearly a better version than what
happened in the game I mean I was I was
suggesting like b3 and I was kind of
surprised with a b3 but he also he's
hoping for the slight queenside edge
because rope a5 Bishop Utley before his
pieces are just ever so slightly better
by the way is most b6 a good decision
what happens if c6 now in the wire look
at the current game position hasn't it
actually become kind of interesting now
so this beep so you're like huh but okay
so we'll see six this should be for its
before seven first well CSUN I think you
go to cut fate and I don't have a way
through
okay but okay I'm a new woman I cannot
be here for ya
ooh
strong idea that point everybody of D
takes you opened up the c-4 square for
the night yeah
suddenly c7 and 96 is winning that's
that's officials idea here behind you
for and if you take D - you take f5 and
suddenly c7 and Bishop a6 is just
winning by sport so sorry just
translating some of the obvious tactics
to make sure everyone's following so
what's the point on e4 you'd have to
play like Bishop e6 and just keep it but
then I would take a bishop takes and c7
well now c7 actually well no and Bishop
a 6 7 7 we should takes D - I'll have
route d7 yep which I wouldn't have if I
played Bishop desserts
Wow no but you could go to f8 actually
after c7 but then Knight c4 or Bishop c4
it should be winning right yeah yeah
Bishop c4 is more exact because then I
just went clinically clinically yeah you
just force the features of the board
like c4 and Bishop c5 and that would be
became the queen so let you make chest
look so easy Vichy is anyone ever told
you that making this look easy I love
this okay so so what what do you do want
anymore then I mean I think you take it
I think I would have to play the April
yep and 94 Bishop c5 and try to acclaim
that I'm dominating
he damn hopeful as auditioning tonight
and the other Bishop is still
controlling ch
I'm not thrilled but it seems to be
enough
but if you're one how this feels like
the practical tribe because all other
moves feel like black is getting out of
this totally unscathed
right yeah also if I start here with
it'll be seven yeah you go all the way
to f8
but then B six balls but thanks to this
you won't have five you know it's not
like like it's lost because that C pawn
still hasn't Queen and okay yeah I mean
it's a position you're saying we're okay
clearly White's better but it's not not
like black is just busted here he's
actually in an ideal kind of defensive
setup and he has an extra pawn and
especially if we can bring his look
around right that's a much better
defensive setup than to wait on the
other side that's a great point just
instructive for the viewers to not
settle on the passive Brooke and look
for an active way to I mean if something
like this happens and you get the rook
here black is in a much better defensive
setup to hold this so okay interesting
can black start with a more active work
instead of like working a fate can you
play yeah baby Brooke d8 immediately ID
seven with let's see OC seven so check
one check can you do and I was just
gonna rip see one Roxie - I don't know
if I have time for it yeah okay let's
try this strange move III by the way
like baby be a check King g7 and then
play but then you can take and I thought
I can take and I get Brooks avoid then
it's not so easy so II for the e4 Knight
c4 Bishop c5 and then try to rush in
with route d8 maybe it'll be seven is
too slow maybe I should start with C Sun
right prevent 48 actually so now when
the brook moves even if you just go
first
and these poet doesn't have this rook t8
idea
okay it seems like Alec senko should be
in a decent position to hold by the way
both sides under mutual o.e force been
played look at look at this we're
predicting the main game but only three
minutes for Wang Hao for the next 11
moves seven minutes for Alex n Co this
is gonna be a mutual time Scrabble week
we haven't looked at this but now I'm
just thinking after d4 kind of finite 64
it takes a fall and then c7 rook c8 okay
but sorry yeah Black's not gonna well
Bishop d7 g7 yeah you have to take c7 I
know we should be five and then at
Bishop c5 and I've got my bishop is by
bishops ions which is maybe White has
Bishop e6 check Intermezzo and then and
then take okay thinking h8 looking at
you at them right x e7 and then go
Bishop c5 and play a5 Bishop f3 e4 how
are you gonna make progress I don't know
but at least I'm not in any danger of
losing this one and I know that if I
played the other line I might blunder in
a million different Court unsound and he
is gonna be four okay so we can see Mike
takes e4 but I think it'll be between on
the on the on the white board there we
see D takes e4 is played and now yeah
let's see unite c4
[Music]
you
I feel like with two minutes left and if
I'm wrong how I can't see everything
here so Knight takes e4 feels like the
safe option knights and floor feels like
I need to win this game and I'm trying
to take the lead of this kid that's
tournament but it does have the risk of
having to make ten moves in two minutes
with the increment but you're down two
pawns to start with and your king isn't
so safe this you you know what you think
is gonna happen here I have no idea
I mean I just don't think Knight takes
e4 is the move of a man who is just play
d4 I think wasn't even a date you know
winning this is white just white my
destiny or something so I'm trying to so
maybe you could argue his Knight is
quite misplaced then and black has time
for rook c8 and Bishop d6 or something
well let's see I don't really expect 94
it seems like an abrupt change of heart
to me but is there any merit to throwing
in c7 first where you haven't kind of
chosen yet because if you play c7 the
rook right and then okay so
the brook goes all the way to FA do we
go back to night C for obviously hitting
b6 so Bishop c5 is played but now
there's no there's no rook on c8 Bishop
d6 ideas rook b7 I guess you're kind of
slow playing I don't know but I mean is
this not like a to result position for
white but it isn't there just Bishop c8
and then the King starts marching
towards the pond 7 by the way looks like
it doesn't matter cuz Knight takes e4
has been played we may get that exchange
sacrifice line we've already booked at
good ones Bishop before c7 rook c8 it
takes okay let's ask I mustered at
Messina what happens up to this it's
happening on the board by the way b7 has
been played if we get this line I think
we'll see Bishop e6 check first and then
rook c7 Bishop c5 is vichy said black
Mike seems to be holding the same game
just fine but okay I mean I thought with
opponent c6 it was quite safe but it
seems that my how evaluated this
position as well as idiot both right and
so e4 in fact was to clinch the draw
yeah actually it seems like this now at
the rookie fade it should be even easier
to hold the draw right because if you
play Bishop d7 he doesn't check but
actually what is the girl here now
Bishop d7 Bishop i5c eight rooks a
bishop see it and that's the drawers
yes right yeah yeah
yes the shoulder line everybody if
Bishop a5 c8 takes takes Bishop takes
white wins the bishop but it doesn't
matter this is yeah these will be drawn
again for black with two points for the
exchange
yep oh so you think that that was the
evaluation that one actually evaluated
his chances is worse if he doesn't take
Knight takes e4 anything with I see yeah
all right okay interesting 19 ships e5
it looks very tempting to play with this
Bishop on c5 and c6 right but you know
you make five more moves and suddenly
black can improve his position like a
Hawaiian so right that happens to me a
lot
who's walking umm but yeah okay so
Bhishma five played and we're gonna get
the exchange exchange up and game for
white with no real winning chances that
it has been predicted actually I think
Alex Ian go could have played Bishop c5
allowed c8 rook c8 Bishop Satan played
Bishop f3 and f4 f5
I'm not claiming he really has many
chances but it's a much cooler way to
draw maybe we should have three here and
then clay Iggy for an f5 I think this is
slightly unpleasant huh
why oh wait my god if anybody is nothing
it's almost yes yeah but it's not really
black so by the way let's let's quickly
flash over to the NBL neck seam looks
like he's kind of just agreed that he
blew this one and gonna be a draw wait
no no that's clearly a real a slit look
at that hey the movies would take g8 and
the relay says black played rook f8 I'm
pretty sure that's a we call that a DG t
error digital game transmission error
yeah that move most certainly did not
happen yeah no it must be even better
with little captures and Jake and keep
sliding along so rooked okay looks like
we've been reset the trade happened on
g8 rook takes h4 h5 I think we're gonna
see an extension of hands here or draw
very or no handshake these days but
we're gonna see a draw very soon yeah so
so what do you do if you're if you're in
Mac seams corner vichy you're you're his
coach for a second how do you get him to
kind of shake this one off I guess at
this point you have to go back to the
drawing board and see for sure was white
really winning at some point we kind of
think maybe there was a chance yes I
mean we thought instead of well the line
who is Lee said seemed convincing but
yeah it was close enough close enough to
feel that Maxime you know it's gonna
regret this one maybe when you add an
extra mole for more dramatic effect and
it turns out to be the one that we can
do position just enough not to make it
work what can you do and will this you
something that I was I always say there
in commentary is of course people miss
things all the time that's not the
problem but when you have so much time
remaining and you rush the decision and
that's the ends up being the wrong
decision it feels like you just kind of
bash your head why
and I spend of my fifty five minutes I
have compared to my opponents two and
half minutes why didn't I just spend ten
minutes looking at the position it was
clear that white was better or had the
chances of any of the two players at
that point so I know I've I frequently
feel that sometimes people rush these
decisions instead of taking a bit more
time and it comes back to bite them
because Maxime of course can calculate
very deeply and thoroughly and if you
give him that opportunity again he
switches his move
but if they I mean it's a mistakes you
can make in chess but then again it's
much easier to see that in hindsight I
mean sometimes we need a hundred percent
convinced or something why why would you
recheck it again right and so that's
also problem I think I Maxime simply
thing and then very late it dawned on
him this fine to sauce max III because
it's this thing at the end of the tail
right I mean it's really not something
you expect to happen well and I think
you make a great point bishop but if I
had to guess and of course we'll
probably find out in postgame interviews
and and make sure everyone reads the
chest comm news report Peter doctors
will bring it to us and I'm sure we'll
have an answer of MBL's thoughts but if
I had to guess I think he made the
mistake right here before Bishop III and
maybe just missed that critical line
with Knight c3 right that if you go for
rookie for now the key point in this
variation if you're just joining us
everybody was that black has this very
very tricky move Knight c3 creating a
double attack and why can't just go all
in here white would lose and the key
move for white was you had to find
rookie four before Bishop a3 at least we
think and maybe just you know a small
misstep there didn't seem didn't seem
like something you needed to double
check and and but ultimately it really
hurt White's um all right
a draw has been agreed I'm told no not
yet okay the draw will happen on the
board look at that
stalemate will happen no yes ah that
would be even bird eeeh
yeah King c1 let the stalemate okay by
the way speaking of another draw as MBL
and grishnack played out Dingley run and
a nice period we okay they've also
agreed okay
the final moves there that we we didn't
follow happened here after Geary's work
a mistake
just board mistake which is put the king
from the square to draw yeah it turns
out to be a blunder I was about to say
that in opponent name but that's because
it's well the move is king before right
would be good for its Bishop a4 yeah
we're analyzing to tell all the fans who
don't understand this joke a made-up
position because at the end of a game
with the big wooden boards you see
that's a dgt board and the way the game
is signifying is a draw they put the
Kings on central squares sometimes the
transmission error can occur there where
it looks like someone has played King d5
but of course that would be a losing
move the actual draw already occurred
with the rooks just going back and forth
so so the quick quick translation of an
inside chess joke that I think a lot of
fans don't don't quite know if they
haven't played with the dgt board what
about this game with Fabiano and au
pomme neo she are we getting no this is
just I think this is a girl I feel like
I brought luck every round has had a
decisive game and this might be our
first round with with all peace
throughout the land
yeah but after a six and B five I still
don't see how it's like and really it's
too little
yeah but very good game and Queen e1 and
f5 is very alert because I mean who if
you change Queens and you solve all you
promise good defense because while we
were watching it it felt it felt pretty
unpleasant public so I think never can
be happy that we have this one in yeah
let's show that variation this she's
talking about was the critical moment to
analyze back here when as you said to us
it felt very unpleasant black had been
under pressure for a while you start
seeing ideas white plays Queen f3
opening up mating threats if you will
but black finds the very alert Queen e1
and then f5 and suddenly the Queen is
frozen here any moves would allow a
queen trade and maybe black is better so
suddenly Fabi has to bail out into the
lines we see where if Queens are traded
we head to an endgame where we're
expecting a draw interesting stuff there
very well defended by Jana I agree
yep and that's a good result for young
obviously drawing with the black pieces
but it will keep him in a share first
place unless something crazy happens in
the final game but that's obviously a
very important to hold off the highest
rated player in the field the pre
tournament favorite but for five and a
Caruana another disappointing result of
course these players are all very strong
and capable of taking on Fabiano but
after losing with the black pieces being
the red only being able to score a draw
with white probably does it's not the
feeling he wanted it from his past two
games yep what are your what are your
thoughts on fabi's form at this point
Vichy as far as the will give you our
perception we were talking about earlier
sometimes it seems that a player can be
very well prepared he won this game with
white versus alex senko in the in the
for f3 nimza which basically seemed like
he got a winning position out of the
prep then yesterday the prep led him to
this good position as black finds this
nice novelty but ultimately wasn't
didn't seem to be playing very well as
black is there what insight can you give
with that when a player feels like hey
I'm well prepared but I don't really
feel like I'm playing well just yet in
the event or or do you not see it that
way
well with the benefit of hindsight I see
that Bobby's preparation was nowhere as
deep as we thought it was okay and in
fact he seems to be gambling no I I
think that's very positive in terms of
his attitude but it wouldn't be gambling
if she succeeded all the time you have
to fail and that's what happen so for
the moment I still I countif Abby is one
of the top four in this even though he's
half point behind because
it's a long tournament and he often
scores heavily in the second half so I
think well it's just too early to start
trying to explain this you know it's
still everything for him to play for and
yeah and in a tournament with this level
you you you can't expect to win everyone
that's it right no no no biggie no
biggie on that front either but on the
other side of things isn't this cave
beyond continued confidence I mean he
won his first game with black and he was
lost
yeah I was in loss and this is this is
third black in four games is that right
yeah what but yam has every right to
feel confident I think
it's also showing a very high level and
I mean resourceful playing well it seems
to be he seems to be comfortable and yep
well the other the only other game going
if you're just tuning in everyone is the
one between Wang Hao and Kirill Alex
ANCA we expect this one to also be a
draw despite tough
despite the rook versus Bishop and
balance black has two points for the
exchange and nothing really to worry
about in the structure and again the one
that we've been looking at here the the
only way someone wins this is if someone
blunders it away so likely well I can
sit tight a six and B five creating a
passed pawn probably doesn't offer
anything although there is you said
maybe there's so in a dream world if
you're gone eight you know you get the
b-pawn somehow you trade the B for the D
pawn and in the end your King is closer
to this side of the board the King side
where the pawns are but likely that's
just not not a reality right yeah I mean
there are five variations where white
goes to head seven and black plays King
f7 and they just take made each other's
right
yeah and I can't see a line that
anything can really happen here and
neither here well on that note we will
take your word for it and expect that
both these games will peter out let you
go until until another day occurs where
where you get to join is Vichy it's it's
a pleasure it's been awesome and thank
you for your thoughts again today we
can't wait to see you on the next show
excellent as always thanks fishy
[Music]
you
and we are back here again chess calms
continued coverage of the 2020 feat a
candidates tournament reminds you of
where we are and eight players that have
not disappointed although with that
being said we may be having our first
round that is gonna not deliver us a
decisive results so I apologize for
bringing the bad luck with me everybody
but we had a close one that ratchet Boff
replacement right there Maxine vache
magrav will he look back ultimately as a
as something he regretted here in round
four but he still has great chances to
be that guy who's gonna face off against
Magnus Carlsen along with Wang Hao and
Jana pom Yoshi he will he will still be
tied for the lead at the end of round
four so these guys Robert I mean I know
we know they're the best players in the
world that's how they got here but it's
always it's always fun to take a look at
that and just remind ourselves of who's
in this event and why this is so much
fun to watch yes eight of the absolute
strongest players in the planet Vishy
Anand is one of the best players in the
world still to this day former world
champion he's joining us for commentary
which is so fantastic players like
Wesley so one of the top players in the
world he is in the chat all the time so
there are a lot of players who if they
were in this field you'd be like yep
okay makes sense you know wouldn't feel
like you're missing out on anything and
you know of course team or Roger Bobb is
the big asterisk because he was
qualified for this event and then
stepped out because of ongoing concerns
rightfully so of Kovan 19 but there's so
many people who could be in this event
but only these eight have qualified or
actually seven of qualified and one was
given a wild card but you know very
deserving players and we've seen nothing
but fighting exciting chess in this
round we are going to see four draws
from four games but that's really crazy
miracle here but yeah yeah dead no
miracles are happening on this board and
we actually were given a quote because
Mexican was interviewed after his game
and he said that he was unhappy with the
results because it felt like he had a
very dangerous initiative
and Sasha didn't have much time but it's
completely fair I didn't see a clear win
for me and it's possible that Sasha just
defended very well I couldn't find more
than a draw so I want with it
I think we can't wait to dive into that
for those of you who maybe haven't been
following we will we will recap quickly
at the end where we think that critical
moment was I'll be doing game of the day
analysis brought to you on our youtube
twitch and everywhere channel so if
you've been following those videos I'll
be going right from this to recording
that video we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna dive a little bit into that and
see if we can figure out where Maxime
went wrong in that one so check that out
if you haven't been subscribing to our
content and other places please do so so
let's remind everybody of how this game
doesn't end when Vichy was here we were
joking about the funny ideas of how you
somehow win a king upon any will show
why white shouldn't play a move like
Bishop before just to make it clear that
going into a king upon ending where your
opponent has an outside passer and you
don't is is how you would lose this kind
of position although this you pointed
out a funny line that maybe eventually
there's some weird stalemates but this
would be an example where this pawn is
won for this pawn but blacks king is
ultimately closer so those are kind of
things you don't play in these end games
that's how you would lose I'm really
good at finding those kind of routes the
benefit of having an outside pass pollen
becomes very clear in King and pawn it's
less clear with more pieces on the board
but when is the materials whittle down
it's like your king is about to go on a
journey out to catch that pawn and then
the enemy king will scoop up the rest of
material let's keep the the live board
there above I want to flash the other
four three games that finish just to
remind you the only one continuing is
between Fabiano Caruana Jelena pom neon
she will keep that there for you the
critical moment maybe in this game
between MVL and Grichuk was way back way
back in the position where with tons of
time pressure
maybe maybe Maxine plays a little too
fast here it felt like one that black
was just barely holding on though to be
fair we couldn't find a knockout blow
totally either he ultimately goes for
this forcing variation that doesn't
yield enough and they had for a rook
that ultimately was held by Sasha crook
and and so that's how that one finished
the game between one cow and Alek Senko
was agreed to withdraw here despite the
extra exchange nothing to do when your
opponent has two pawns with the bishop
and no real weaknesses for the rook to
target everything bye-bye black is
easily held I think the most impressive
draw was maybe by Dingley Rennes okay no
Krisha for sure but we both felt looking
at the game earlier I don't know where
to go back to but I mean certainly I own
and move 25 with a four we felt that the
pawn and the night Robert this looked
like a two result position that Dingley
red would squeeze but a nice Giri made
kind of quick work of this draw got to
give him credit right yeah he played as
precisely as you can when your position
where only your opponent has winning
chances perhaps it wasn't quite as bad
as it looks
but optically it's very important there
that's a critical decision by playing 94
trading off the Knights and getting rid
of White's best piece and making the a
four pawn more vulnerable so a nice
decision there by a niche and that line
led to more simplification ultimately
blacks King was actually the more active
of the two and so it was it was a pretty
easy decision
they repeated moves and eventually
agreed on the draw so that's that's our
quick TL DR too long didn't read if
you're one of the very few who might
just be tuning in thanks to although we
had more than 12,000 of you one point
that have been with us throughout the
day across few different platforms and
very active chats we appreciate how
engaged you guys are we also had some
active questions for you we had a daily
question and then we had some active
engagement on social media given how
round three ended and Fabiano Caruana is
very long drawn-out loss versus ding Li
Ren Wesley so I think was partly joking
but you know definitely drawing
attention the fact that Fabi could have
resigned for many moves we asked you
guys whether whether you thought it was
disrespectful at all or if it ever
should even be considered disrespectful
at swooosh it screws with varma 17 says
it's a lot better than two super gems
accepting a draw in a not so drawers
position Touche
Robert I think that's a good answer well
you know my feelings about you know the
draw
as was heard around the world during
round 12 of the 2018 World Chess
Championship but that is a very good
answer I'm with you there and we have
another answer bye sugah Cuccia saying
it depends on the loss position we
thought you could let that one go robber
anyway continue good in a queen and king
versus king is disrespectful of course
but others there's enough resources to
give the opponent of the last chance for
mistake totally fair
crispin Sedna and other sports you also
don't just surrender if it's dead and
lost I agree I think a lot of people
feel like maybe the opposite of our
question to be honest I think a lot of
people might feel like you know they
wish more games were played out to check
me right I think that sometimes as
hardcore chess fans we can take for
granted the fact that the position seems
clearer to us than it does to people who
are maybe just learning learning the
game and maybe sometimes playing it on
farther is it something people would
appreciate but anyway interesting stuff
thanks for playing along with us using
the official hashtag we will have more
daily questions for you every day Bishop
d2 played now these guys are are gonna
tickle tickle this one here for a little
bit d5 is played if anybody has small
winning chances I guess we would say it
is black just because of what Robert
said an outside pass pollen you know
does help at some point if you just play
the fantasy game I did where this King
is somehow taking here and this Kings
taking here only black can win those
types of positions so you know so how
does that get creek how does that it get
created if we're thinking about it like
you got a bishop on d6 and you play b4
and eventually you try to force them
away but doing that actually you know
leaves your king in a passive spot so
most likely this game is just gonna
reach an optimal blockade setup for both
sides and they're just gonna shuffle it
out so famous shuffle exactly how you
just did like is if you're driving a car
I say shuffle you say noise shuffle no
shuffle noise oh wait we're not okay
let's go back to the chest this is what
happens when Danny joins official World
Chess Championship feet I can't its
coverage we dance so I have no words for
what just happened that blue shirt looks
so good on you I have no words for what
you did you just
you just you've left me speechless that
was that was awful that was not that
awful I mean the story of that time
pretty upset
but that that yeah okay you know what's
awful I mean go ahead sorry no we are
gonna take a short break because when we
return we do have a special interview
coming your way so no more of Danny
dancing you can dance
away we'll be back in just a few minutes
so stay tuned everybody
[Music]
you
and we are now joined by a very special
guest grandmaster kirill alex echo who
just finished his game a great game if I
don't say so myself as black drawing
against Wang Hao let me just ask before
we even get into this game we're now
four rounds in how do you feel so far
about your play at the 2020 feeding
candidates it's not so bad but of course
it could be much better I mean I lost
just one game and made free draws okay
yes I mean two days ago I had some
winning chances and let's see them in in
other games I had to struggle to make
address so I'm waiting for the white
color finally well you've shown
incredible defensive resourcefulness
throughout this event your game against
Chris shock in the first round had
everybody just praising your tenacity
with a movie six in particular was we
had Vishy Anand in the commentary he
loved that move in that decision you
made so what's it been like do you feel
like now that you're four rounds in that
you're getting your comfort and it's
just another tournament or is there
still nerves because it's such a big
stage
I think it's not about nerves I mean
it's just quite difficult to equalize
for black color and I always got quite
bad positions after the open so I had
nothing to do this just trying to
defense from the open end well talk
about this particular game I've press
play and let the fans who may just be
joining us see a replay of your battle
here with one hell but at what point did
you feel like you started to get a bad
position
we-we-we definitely must be Roque six
move okay so it's not accurate okay what
do you think I could have done here okay
I could take first knife or also ever
move 94 okay what maybe Queen a4 is this
just the most simple in this position
so so what was your what was was there a
miscalculation on rock a6 after e3 and
this variation by the way I also do you
like instead of every Bishop a forest
Bishop a tree root kit and somebody's
would be should be for Queen a foreign
oxacillin I thought it this is also
quite interesting for it because now the
black color Bishop is on before it's
just right White's Bishop very strong b7
hanging were you surprised at all at
wrong house decision to not take back on
be free with with the night we we spent
a lot of time feeling that he he
actually maybe let his advantage slip by
not playing the kind of obvious
recapture and I take speak but the trick
is that after night be free I play okay
then
trying to change that rooks this series
coming yeah because after rooks c7 f ef
rubia and okay then just okay also have
b6 basics yeah of course you didn't feel
that he necessarily had a had a big
enough advantage to claim winning
chances in the despite I'm a dad do
basement for k-6 the position is still
very solid on
realize that most of all to defend
anyway
okay I was gonna say to take a step back
then even though you feel maybe that
your you could have been playing better
you feel like you've had some tough
positions is there may be some advantage
to the fact that through four rounds
you've had to think your way out of some
tough spots right you found this really
great resource against grow up you've
defended now a couple other tough games
and do you feel like maybe if you can
get the white pieces that that your
calculation and the fact that you're a
little bit a little bit warmed up is
gonna help later on I hope so I don't
know how it will be but yeah at least
it's not so bad it is it was like after
second game or right yeah after third
game I think I started to find my own
game and is getting better from from
from the game to the game
yes it definitely appears to be the case
and you know as you look across this
tournament here are their you know the
biggest surprise at the start was doing
the rent losing his first two games
before kind of writing the ship is there
anything been surprising to you or it's
just such a top level tournament that
you know anything can happen in usually
I'm pretty sure he would ever lose to
first games but in this work is he spent
two weeks before the tournament in the
quarantine so yeah and I think it
happened right now and nobody knows
maybe tomorrow the tournament will be
postponed or
yeah I just we can't predict that
made it even harder to feel kind of
settled and prepare for the event with
so much of the uncertainty going on and
not being sure what's going to happen
with all everything happening with the
cove in nineteen
yeah bit it's quite difficult to
understand that at any point the
tournament can be stopped right you
never know
yeah even if even if that unfortunate
though understandable case might happen
I would say that while you're there I
you you certainly deserve to be there
you want you wanted a rather brilliant
game at the chest calm feet a grand
Swiss / someone named Robert Hess do you
think Robert Hess for being here in the
candidates is Robert really the person
to thank for your success thank you
Robert I guess I did start your streak
of good results in because seriously
Kirill you've been playing great and we
couldn't be happier for you we wish you
the best of luck and hope to have you
again on the show really appreciate you
joining us very much thanks girl thanks
have a good one there this is Kirill
Ilyich Senko who courteous enough to
join us it's been awesome awesome having
these guys check in live from on-site
on-site and this young man has a very
very bright future in Russia only 22
years of age so barely legal which is
reminding Robert of his favorite movie
Legally Blonde and you know I was gonna
say before you went on unnecessary
pop-culture references that he was he's
so nice that he almost made me say
you're welcome for hitting me in the
chest game like he says thank you oh
you're welcome you're very welcome like
we know you're not welcome I've lost
that chess game I'm still a little upset
about it I don't know you thought where
I was going with it cuz I prefaced it
with like you know the preparation and
like you've won a lot of great games but
you know what we're more important than
Grand Master Robert Hess I love that I'm
Vicki selling where I was going no but
he he's a very kind guy and we analyzed
the game afterwards and we'd spoke at
the tournament just you know I feel like
he's unnecessarily received some flack
like the fact that he's the wild-card
was out of his control
and he did everything in his power
played good chess played the game
studied hard and he was chosen the wild
car and he was performing so well that
he was even eligible for a wild-card
spot
I think it's unfortunate for the
individual maybe the system has some
problems but for Carrillo X Hank of
himself he's done nothing but play great
chests over the last couple of years and
a lot of people have their eyes on him
maybe this won't be his can this
tournament to win and end up playing
Magnus Carlsen the World Championship
but he held his own against Magnus and
their head-to-head game in the Isle of
Man and he's proven game after game here
that he is fighting and he does have to
work on his openings with the black
pieces he was the first to say that but
today wasn't one of those days but he
just had this inaccuracy with work a6
and he's fortunate the position was so
solid that didn't cost him anything
major but in other games that certainly
will cost him so he needs to right the
ship in that regard yeah and you said I
mean obviously the system you know might
deserve some flak and and those a lot of
things go into organizing the feed at
Grand Prix and on stuff but but overall
I think you could also understand why
the organizers chose him he's only 22
years old right he may be the Brighton
staight you know shining star for the
future of Russia and and their top chess
players right so you know this is
certainly whether he wins the event or
not we're not saying he may not but
certainly a great opportunity for him
and we expect him to continue to to be a
major star in the chess world for years
to come he'll be playing for Team Russia
versus Team USA in an upcoming team
chess event we're gonna have here on the
site as well so for those of you who are
becoming Alex anko fans look for him to
be more a part of some stuff we're doing
here on chess calm some all right not
really anything has changed here as
we've predicted this is a gonna be a bit
of a staring contest
White's not gonna risk going for
anything that allows black to win the
deep on and then win the King upon
ending outside past pawn tricks will
will not be something fabi Falls for but
at the same time there's no real
progress for for yan to make right no no
way to no way to force white into ideas
like that so what's amusing to me Danny
is that Yan rushes decisions in harder
positions than this and in this game
he's spending time right now in a
position that looks like there's no
progress to be made so curious indeed
but you know he's entitled it's
he's trying to win this tournament face
magnus carlsen and i just don't see
anything
he's got the blockade the bishop goes to
d6 to prevent the king going to c5 then
the King comes e5 if the bishop goes to
d6
like you were mentioning earlier the
King and Bishop cannot share a square
and you would like to have both the king
and the bishop on d6 they're not
happening so the King lacks access
anytime you play before the pawn will be
captured like your Bishop goes to d6 and
played before the King will run over and
this is not amounting to anything so the
position ultimate theory on why I think
yan is slowing down here I think that
sometimes when you were on the worse
side of a game for the majority of it
and you defended resourcefully now now
you're the only one who can maybe win
and and you kind of want to let that
feeling sit for a bit
right I mean even if he understands it's
it's a far-fetched to believe Bobby
doesn't hold this thing in black is like
well you know I'd love to think of some
crazy crazy way that I use this outside
past pawn and eventually win an endgame
and if nothing else I'm just gonna let
Fabiano sit in a position that he has no
chances to win for a little bit I think
some of that stuff pays dividends down
the road maybe psychologically I don't
know but Bobby knows those are not
thinking or are you just moving because
he knew his position is completely level
so I definitely get what you're saying
it's nice to stew in a position where
you're have the upper hand but right now
feels like a situation where they both
know the draw is coming and well maybe
dinner isn't open yet is that part of it
right and chat can continue to ask
questions if there's some things about
this that you don't understand and maybe
Robin are taken for granted I see a
question from coin coin up something
asking about giving check here this
would be a mooger to be careful about
you don't want to check the King into an
entry point on the Kings side right
where something like King f6 and King g7
that would be a way you lose this game
so part of the reason we're saying it's
a draw is that we don't expect those
types of moves to be played by either
side right that would you know Rhodes
for black to lose would be to force this
white King in Rhodes for white to lose
would be for white to eventually over
commit to this side of the board and
eventually allow black to win over here
neither side is going to allow that
right what you're going
sees a staring contest and opposition
stance over over here on the D file and
and most likely it's just gonna be a
shuffling until we have three move
repetition but if there's other
questions you want to ask
keep it up shout out to the chat we've
had a lot of you active and with us all
day and we do appreciate your support
the we just got a great question now
that yo for it s portions and the
question is would a bishop exchange
still be a draw now it depends on how
those bishops are exchanged so if black
were to play with a Bishop e6 check but
okay he's gonna be King e5 with Bishop
da but yeah good but as we say if black
were to play Bishop d6 said of b6 in and
then let's say Bishop where does my
Bishop go we find the analysis board and
take a deeper look at it so let's say
you want to look at Bishop d6 instead of
what was played yeah you have to show
that King and pawn a and Bishop a5 yep
b4
before BLB for king c 464 so this is bad
for black because when the bishop trades
on before and the king takes on before
you need your King to already be on d6
if you're black so you can capture on d5
but let's say you make a move like
Bishop FA you can go you'll win my H
pawn that's what you need to do but the
bishop trade itself doesn't work out
because my King comes back to defend my
past deep on and then white is ahead so
you'd have to be able to capture on d5
before the King gets back so your kink
and then run over to the other pawns
this would be fair black won't played
before position like this you actually
be careful about things like Bishop f4
in some cases although still probably
likely a draw but uh this should be six
check was played and I had just
responded you a question Chad saying
this is not a move you're gonna see cuz
King e5 in here but after King e5 I
guess the move you don't want to play as
yet another check don't chase the King
into f6 where it can come to g7 so I'm
expecting after a king e5 Bishop d8 and
nothing has really changed in the
position at all right because that white
king will then have to go back towards
that be pawn because what you don't want
to have happen is Bishop e7 pawn before
and your king is like slower to get back
and if the official of d2 will be stuck
defending the King side pawn as the it's
on the square of the dark colored bishop
so the bishop could sit on have fade and
attack that pawn and if you're not
careful but the white king will rush
back over the Queen side and tie the
black Bishop down
so essentially neither side has the
opportunity to accomplish what they're
seeking to achieve and in that case
likely they will just be repeating moves
and maybe Bishop e6 check is the start
of that if King V 5 is met by Bishop d8
and Bobby just goes back maybe we'll see
a repetition occur immediately with
something like Bishop to b6 check and no
no progress to be made so if you're just
tuning in this has been round four of
the 2020 feat a candidates as you can
see all games were drawn the game that
probably had us most most on mostly on
the edge of our seat was MBL's battle
versus Alexander Grichuk look for some
game of the day video action coming
coming your way in our on our youtube
twitch and other other channels so make
sure you're subscribing to those we're
bringing you daily video reviews of the
biggest games in addition to our live
coverage so we're gonna I'm gonna be
diving into that one with some analysis
right when our show is done in fact
maybe you should just close it out and I
can get started because I got a lot of
work to do got a you know analyze the
game record a video you've probably got
nothing else to do after this you're
probably taking a nap
probably I'm definitely taking that
don't you act like you don't know what
I'm gonna do we've been doing commentary
together for years so don't come here
being like oh you closes out I don't
know what you're up to later you know
exactly what I'm up to later yeah and
yet you're trying to play all in a sinan
you play it at all just try to bring out
it's the first three days first three
rounds of commentary and they come in
here and try to slack off and leave
early no no no sir
you're Saints the very end I would never
do that to you I was testing you now I
know you want me so I'll stay I get you
know like any good toxic relationship
I'm constantly testing our love um
anyway let's remind everybody of the
love that our deep insights pull out our
analysis to over at chess dot-com /
analysis gives us in depth in depth the
statistical breakdowns of what's going
on in the game within the game if you
will from round three we had some
interesting reports not a huge surprise
that this this game Ark stayed close to
equal the entire time neither one of
these guys really gave an inch and
therefore the game ended in peace
remember you can see our see our
breakdowns we often have this stuff
going on our news reports I share I
share some individual stats when we do
game of the day videos and you can run
any game you want through chest comms
analysis tool to get your own kind of
breakdowns the big one was ding li Ren
versus father in a car wanna that was
the one that really really revealed by
far Fabiano's worst game statistically
to this point very low accuracy score
for him age six was the move that was
given the biggest deficit marks I
actually think there were some earlier
mistakes in that game Robert that also
caused caused his his eventual loss but
your thoughts on that yeah no age six
was the move that I most heavily
criticized during the live analysis and
that doesn't mean that there weren't
other mistakes but at that moment when
he still had a position that was yeah
alright for him he played aged six and
that's when it really started tanking
the evaluation went up and up as you see
there for Bingley bread and he was like
walking up a staircase just an escalator
there and this it was an insurmountable
advantage by the end so for Dingley Ren
it was the comeback he needed for
Fabiano it was perhaps the start of a
subpar to game streak here but there's
so much time left in this tournament
that plenty of chances for all
the other game that ended in peace was
anis Geary's battle versus Maxine vache
de Graaf a balanced evaluation I like
that I like that term balanced no real
blunders from either side know even
inaccuracies from either side that's uh
that seems like what we call a forced
forced prepare draw borderline nothing
really to that one our last draw we're
sorry go ahead
no that was a peaceful affair but the
next game that we have the numbers for
shook and won had that was anything but
we're sure Kevin advantage to route and
as you see g5 essentially shook was so
upset with himself because he said I saw
this idea that was followed up she found
many four checks I saw it in a different
position I knew it didn't work then and
in the position he allowed it he just
forgot that suddenly it could work and
he spoiled what was a nice looking
position advance she could have pressed
forever but he allowed immediate
liquidation and intraoral so the numbers
don't lie and Sasha were shocked doesn't
lie
I know your life
my lips are moving I was wait I thought
I was gonna be a cute get your lips
moving on camera their team t3 plate
instead of king e5 I wonder I reacted to
your pop-culture reference and then you
changed back to the chest so now I know
how this works that when I actually join
in with you you don't want to play
anymore you just want me to want to like
you do want to I want you to want me so
what do you say I need you to need me oh
my god love for you to love me and I'm
definitely begging you to beg me to get
back on chess here okay King to d6 is
gonna be met by king e4 followed by
Bishop f4 so there's really nothing to
it I'm just I don't know what else to
say besides we're trying to squeeze
water out of a stone here to keep this
thing entertaining
that was the song reference you haven't
heard in a while begging you to bet I
got good oh gosh I just didn't need your
cheap tricks here yeah is there anything
going on here there's no one that went
over your head you thought I was making
a chess reference but cheap trick is the
band that sing that song for Danny well
there's still no progress to be made I
guess both sides are kind of opening up
the door of inviting the other to play
for a win almost kind of weirdly
he's down admit the draw I think Bishop
f4 will be played to hold the d6 square
see three is gonna allow King d6 because
it can be met by king e4 and then Bishop
check so it doesn't matter they're both
neither wants to play the most obvious
moves that just prevent progress and
make a draw they want to continue to
invite and entice some potential blunder
like b4 would probably not be the best
move
I'm guessing cuz then white can move and
then try to get King c4 so that doesn't
really instructive moment so b4 okay
Bishop d2 King d6
uh-huh King c4 b3 is Bishop f4 check you
know kicks here came back before I take
your pawn yeah a key that you don't take
the bishop by the way everybody because
b2 and suddenly black is winning but you
kick the King back and then take the
pawn and there's no d5 trade so I what's
interesting is even this probably has
some drawing chances although certainly
white would be the one trying to win I
actually probably would be winning with
the extra D pawn and eventual threats of
of entry to the Kings side so again
neither side is gonna blunder here
neither side is really gonna give an
inch and neither me nor Robert will miss
an opportunity to remind you to hang out
with us for the for the rest of March
and into April because we don't have a
lot of other friends so tell all of your
friends to join us and be with us for
the entire fee day candidates tournament
here on chest comm and that was really
sad you know trying to have people pity
you to join you you should join the show
every single time because it's fun it's
entertaining there is a lot of
educational aspects to chess analysis
and there's Danny making silly puns that
really don't need to be made and yet
we're all here for them so how is that
Danny did I pitched that well enough you
did great thank you thank you
but this game though so this game okay
I think yawn and father are playing this
out because they know that they'll get
puns from you at the stage they've seen
enough of your commentary just keep it
on camera well let's you know jokes on
them let's actually get something out of
this time together well actually let's
keep the analysis board up so that we
can leave them behind and go go check
out I just want to go back and analyze
this MBL game this is all like it is I
can't stop thinking about this one I
want to figure out where the win was if
anything and it's not just because I'm
doing a video of it right after the show
here I think it is why you're doing this
exactly why I'm doing it
so let's get a preview into my analysis
so I think that up to this point we had
a pretty good field the thread was was
pretty obvious in terms of where White's
compensation was going to be on the F
file I mean this this point here where
h5 and g4 came we were really calling
for it but now after Merck h8 and a four
yeah I want to look at this line again
with rookie four how does black hold
this
okay you can't move the bishop lose the
night just to point out the obvious for
everyone things with b5 are consistently
losing you could you could give jack or
sac the exchange right away the point is
that we win the f7 pond and have a huge
attack so the only move on on rookie
four was Bishop to e6 pretty
consistently if you trade here black
takes here and then wins the H pawn with
two pieces for the rook black is
probably doing fine so we thought Knight
takes c6 and after F takes rook c5 and
the point is the knight is hanging oh no
no the point was not rook she fired the
point was the bishop she thought yep
after Qingyi rook f3 which this is so
hard
ya think about because all the other
moves like rook g5 came with a tempo
with the g7 pawn this is just trying to
get to f7 and then eventually get to e7
so that's why Robert you talk about this
a lot what are the hardest things to
consider and okay you're doing this in
your head you're calculating as deeply
as you can in a variation like this
where you're trying to prove
compensation you're already down upon
his way it's hard to consider lines that
will involve a crucial move at some
point of a retreating rook to f3 that
holds the c3 square right it's just such
a hard thing to see ahead of time right
and you're actually down to bonds if I'm
not mistaken so now you're down to
because the 8-ball just fell right yeah
so you're you're down to pawns and
you're not even going with direct
threats you're just saying that if I
land a rook on f7 and then that work is
going to get to e7 you're toast
but to stab the foresight to come up
with that is really difficult because
you're visualizing these positions you
don't make the moves on the board and
say oh I don't really like the way it
looks and take it back so commentators
get to do and so as a player you're
thinking about what you're thinking over
g5 here attacks g7 wait worked e5
doesn't work and you kind of discard the
variation and that's where it becomes
tricky because you're going down so many
different branches of moves
you're not just compartmentalizing and
saying alright I'm storing this let me
after this ft c6 let me look for other
moves you can't just throw it away
because you've so much other analysis to
do and that's a shame and MBO you know
he understood that he was better he was
pressing and he gave credit to Chris
Chuck for defending well and Sasha did
defend well but you know he left
something on the table
t3 and pause MPO zi says you guys made
me find a love for chess thank you
proffered
are you crying no there's onions man
who's cutting those onions yeah who just
came in the office is started cutting
onions hot jokes aside thank you thank
you everyone that's here we appreciate
we appreciate you watching so it's uh
it's been honestly a great a great
tournament the the the chess has been
very exciting every round has delivered
a decisive game at least one until this
round where as you can see that live
position squeeze between Fabiano Caruana
and jana pom yoshi assuming that game
ends in a draw and that we're not about
to see a crazy blunder from anyone and
this will be our first round with only
draws but as we were showing here and
again the critical point here is when
this night moves or gets defended the
doubling on the F file for white rook f7
rookie 7 is a very strong threat
although look at this night to be six
and then into d5 maybe well then you
take g7 and then you you probably
promote the h5 h6 h7 I thought maybe I
mean obviously if you're holding the the
most devastating part of the threat
there is always the you know running of
the a pawn over here but likely likely
white it's just too fast so a v h6
a4 h7 is yeah it's actually just very
quickly game over so well well we'll
find out whether Maxime really did miss
that opportunity or or actually let's uh
let's take a look actually look at that
our team working super hard has already
run this game through our server side
very in-depth game report and guess what
it should be three indeed was the
blunder was the missed opportunity and
that means in the critical position we
were talking about that rook a4
Ricky four was the critical move order
as Wesley so said at the time he was
hanging out in the game Chad thanks for
Wesley even when he's not joining us
Robert on camera he's bringing value to
the show we appreciate Wesley tuning in
he's just here for you is a huge he told
me he's got that full closet full of I
heart Robert Hess and I'm Robert has
number one fan shorts
he broke
dates on days odd days though so strange
[Laughter]
Wesley seriously Wesley did give us a
couple of critical lines if you're just
tuning in he was analyzing hanging out
in the chestnut um shop that Bishop III
check first and then rookie for didn't
work because what we for we first
thought this was winning Robin and I and
the key was this looked very devastating
both the knight and the pawn or hanging
but black has this really surprising
in-between move and you can't take g7
because then you would lose material and
that seems to be holding everything with
that with that in mind we are pretty
sure Bishop a3 was played too quickly by
Maxine meeting maybe he missed that
exact idea and if he had taken more time
maybe maybe would have seen the move
over there but again it's very hard to
be critical when as vichy said when he
was with us right it's really difficult
when you're pretty sure you're winning
with a line to not just go for it but in
the end rookie 4 looks like it would
have been better because now Bishop e6
can be met by a different idea sort of
rook g5 Bishop g5 and rook f3 this is
just amazing but add that to be to the
list of things that have been exciting
from this tournament maxime missing a
win here maybe as white in round 4
yep well I got nothing else I'm looking
at looking at the game between Caruana
and upon Miyagi and just thinking that
it's just
time to go home
yeah they were just you know kind of
moved back and forth here but they're
not moving back and forth so that
they're repeating the position they're
just move in and not repeating so that
means no draw can be reached until they
repeat three times
you
oh man I love you chat I know sometimes
that we don't get along I just want to
tell you I'm happy you're here yet
there's even like two people over a mix
or one of them is watching ninja and the
other ones watching us man very exciting
my cricket sound effect is not working
so just say cricket working hard or
hardly work in a Mac right but shout out
to the team working super hard with
these events seriously we got we got a
long we got a long event ahead of us I
gotta I'm gonna have to calm down my
adrenaline or like I'm gonna hit that
crash at some point let me hit the wall
you uh you know you were up very early
today that's for sure
2:30 a.m. to be exact what time is it
it's 8:50
good follow-up - any time you say a time
do you know where your kids are but you
probably do because they're at home
they're probably sleeping here on the on
the west coast one of the things they
don't do a lot of us wake up and watch
dad's just shows
very disappointing shocking as that
sales
all right king c7.r we do we have a we
have a liftoff here nope you trying to
bring the qingyan yep that's what i
wanted i want to play king b6 and work
my way around but i think as soon as
your king gets to b6 so like go Bishop
g7 Bishop g7 king b6 Bishop e5 so I wait
till you can't gets to b6 and now you
can't trade because my D pawn is very
fast
what a fun line it would be some king
upon ending where white is winning
because he's Queenie would check
Oh or is he
the draw actually now it's winning for
white probably we would check and then
you convert the queen of pawn ending the
second you go when you're eight seven
point but there you have a typical kind
of but don't go to be for gonna be six
okay
worst-case scenario white converts with
something like this and this is probably
actually an easily winning ending it's
just really Qingyun yep so alright so
point proven
you can't just offer a trade although
now he plays Bishop g5 is he planning on
meeting King b6 with Bishop d8 Chuck
maybe yep
so
King b6 bishop d8 is there anything that
black can do to try to escape this
doesn't look like it
now I'm seeing more ways films lose for
black than to win
yeah he's he's pushing a little bit as
king d3 king c3 or a king wherever
black and still just cost you wait
robert's making a good point here if you
move the bishop
maybe you allow me to advance d6 yeah
but your king goes to b6 like things
we're just kind of repeating the
opposition at times and it's exactly
what we said 20 moves ago they're just
tricking us into thinking this could
possibly be exciting which is if either
side pushes for a win that's how they
could lose but otherwise this is like
this is frozen territory so we're gonna
make like Elsa let it go we're gonna
take a very very quick break when we
come back we will likely be wrapping up
the last game going here on round 4
giving you our final thoughts don't go
anywhere
more of chest comm coverage of the feat
eight candidates in just a couple
minutes
[Music]
you
all those of you starting to think about
what you're gonna do with the rest of
your Saturday don't worry you can stay
in touch with this incredibly exciting
game between vivillon or Caruana and
yonder pom Yoshi on the go all you have
to do is download the chess calm match
app click the watch tab find the game
and there you have it you can see that's
a screenshot from my very own profile
right there at the top I recognize that
little icon that little avatar that
picture is way out of date I have got to
change that but thanks for being with us
this game Robert at this point I think
you're with me and let's just hope one
of these guys blunders
I don't root for blenders I'm not you
whatever
just cuz they called you the one-hit
blunder when you were a kid doesn't
internet you got to take it on other
people I told you that in confidence I
just came up with a new Danny's high
school nickname for you is not accurate
I've made so many blunders right but
otherwise it's great even how many of
them are famous right yep
by the way look at that look at him
calling the bluff of the H pawn king d4
says take it and again aloud d6 where
suddenly black might be losing the
yeah you seem like you're really a full
thought right now I was just gonna say
it's just uh a game of a game of tickle
and and who's Elmo in this equation
always always Tickle Me always the shout
out to everybody with us obviously if
you have any questions you know not to
say this is an ama but obviously we have
a very very long event ahead of us still
9 more rounds to go ten more round nine
more doing the math apparently is not my
thing but we've got many many days ahead
here of coverage from the feed eight
candidates will bring up the full
schedule to remind you that Robert and I
will be back at it tomorrow no yep
tomorrow March 22nd around 5:20 third
round six another free day three days
apart but as you can see we will be
rolling through this thing into early
April and we hope you tune in and watch
every day if you happen to be a new a
newcomer to the channels where ever
you're watching please hit that
subscribe hit that follow button we do
appreciate it so and this game is
officially over officially just in time
for us and that final schedule shout out
that we did but there you have it round
forward does indeed end in peace our
first round of the 2020 fidei candidates
that did not have at least one decisive
results check out our YouTube channel
where we published first but it'll make
its way to other portals as well I'm
gonna have an in-depth review of Maxine
voce the Groves may be failed winning
chances against Alexandra Grisha coming
up but Robert take us to the standings
here and run everybody of where we stand
after four completed rounds
well united we stand but in addition to
that Danny well you have Jana policy can
be ecstatic about his performance thus
far he has had three black games out of
the first four yet you see him there
tied for first with Maxine but Sheila
Grove and Wang how anyone in first place
is going to be happy but Maxine started
with two whites
he drew Fabiano beating the rent and
drew this game I guess Alexandra shook
with white so Yan is at three blacks
Maxine was at three White's clearly as
we go forward that should be
advantageous for Yan who gets the first
move advantage in more games down the
stretch so Wang Hao played a solid game
we had Kirill Lysenko in the interview
he said I thought I was okay no matter
what but you know there was that slight
poll of missed opportunity and one how
missed an opportunity in round two
against nigiri from a clearly better
position and today he coulda pressed for
more but unfortunately for him he went
awry and didn't get anything to speak of
and well as we go down the rest of the
standings Danny what do you think what
do you make of it Caruana in the middle
of the pack I think you highlighted one
of the most critical points as far as
okay we're obviously like all the rest
of the viewers you know there's still so
much just ahead it would be it would be
fool's gold to pretend that we have a
clear idea yet about anything but I
think I think if we were highlighting
one critical storyline is that yonder
pom Yoshi has probably played the best
chess overall of anybody at least he
gets my vote to this point and the fact
that he's also done that Robert with
three out of four blacks right his his
lone victory coming from the first round
with the black pieces and so if you had
to just pick somebody at this point
who's put themselves in the best
position I think we would agree that
young upon now he seems to be that
person but again so many rounds to play
anything can happen sometimes you see a
player start to find their form and not
even until the back half of the event
right that's why it's a double
round-robin and the players will get
chances at each other with both colors
so you know Caruana and Grichuk right
there in the middle of the pack with two
points but as you as we said I mean
Dingley ren giri alex Enco all three of
those guys would tell us they wish they
played better chess to this point but
the fact that they're only a full point
behind you know better better days may
be yet to come for any one of our eight
competitors so I believe we have our our
pairings for tomorrow to preview for you
so you're sitting here wondering well
what do we have in store tomorrow Dan
well I'm gonna tell you we start out
with giri versus Caruana that'll be an
interesting one onigiri getting the
white pieces
Fabiano switching to black there any
thoughts on that one I think a nice
carrier will plant solidly I'm not
saying he's afraid of Fabiano Caruana
but Anisha minus one right now he
obviously wouldn't love to score a
victory over the world number two but
Fabiano he's a stronger the two players
right now let's be honest and I think
for a nice you don't want to take too
much risk he didn't take a risk in round
one would create preparation but he did
lose that game so while he's still kind
of getting in going in this tournament I
don't think he's gonna try to knock out
Fabiano Caruana and fog on a car one is
a tough customer anyway right
Alexander Grisham will get the white
pieces again Stingley red that'll be an
interesting one obviously grishnack
having had four draws at this point and
if anybody feels kind of robbed I guess
having not gotten a victory yet it might
be it might be Grusha he's played very
well today of course he was worse out of
the opening against a vo but overall
he's been the guy pressing in most of
his games so now with the white pieces
yet again what kind of tough game is
Dingley rent in store for but that's a
guy who's definitely playing better than
he was at the start of the event right
so um not much more to add to that one
besides it's gonna be an exciting one of
course grishnack sitting at two points
Dingley red trailing of one and a half
both those guys desperately needing a
victory to stay stay with the leaders
speaking of the leaders one of them has
maybe the best chance to kind of spread
his wings away a little bit to you Danny
I'm gonna cut you off because Maxime has
the black pieces against acrylic
san'ko's I know what you're gonna say I
was just trying to correct you before
you made that mistake even so I was
gonna say he on paper is playing the
lowest rated player so you know if
you're looking for an opportunity I
guess to to get a victory some of you
think about it like that but I'm glad
you correct him because yes with the
black piece is harder to say that even
if you're leaving the tournament that
you should be expecting a win and
acrylic senko is a very solid player he
has a great approach to the game one
that I really respect and it gets young
upon mushy when he had his only white
pieces of the event so like DePalma
mushy Kirilenko has a three blacks from
his first four games he said you know
I've been struggling with the black
pieces but give me some white pieces and
and maybe we can talk and so he gets
white against mvo who is a predictable
player in terms of his opening
repertoire so Alexa ko has white against
MVL and I'm looking forward into round
six when Alexa ko gets another way to
get some nice giri this is the time for
Alexa anko to gather his confidence and
start pressing his opponents yeah it
would be an interesting storyline for
sure if the lowest rated player got it
got his first victory and took down one
of the tournament leaders the battle I
think of the round though has got to be
the one between the other two tournament
leaders de pomme Nia she taken on Wang
Hal other than MBL as we said those are
the two other guys sitting at two and a
half out of four right now atop the
leaderboard Jana pom now she's getting
white for the only the second time in
five games gonna be exciting to see what
the you know what it's all capable of
the man bun at all I think I think y'all
brings it tomorrow they have a very
short history those two because they've
played I think I don't even know if they
played a dozen games they probably less
than ten I don't know the exact number
but somehow those two players have
avoided each other and I agree with you
Yan seems to be in good shape in this
event he had what looked like a tough
position and what honestly seemed to be
great preparation from Fabien but today
low risk with some upside he he'd made
sure to hold on he just eliminated all
the play to five in a thought he had so
Jana palm she gets the white pieces
against Wang Hao I'm with you that's the
match of the round for sure and I do
believe that Jana Palma she will try to
take it to one how and gather a lead in
this tournament because he doesn't wanna
be tied for too long he wants to score a
very important victory and leave people
behind the dust well I can't wait it
will be Sunday we hope to have all of
you with us and and more so make sure
you tune in to chess comms coverage
tomorrow on behalf of my team here the
staff working bahar the Sun behind the
scenes and the production crew of course
all of our mods and those helping out to
keep the keep the show fun and safe for
everyone we really appreciate it so for
Grand Master Robert Hess International
Master
Danny wrench we will see you tomorrow
with more coverage of the 2020 vitae
candidates tournament